talking about the wind from 100 in your
pocket in the fat guy picture to where
you got to where you are today i mean
you're an entrepreneur i think you're in
the construction industry if i recall i
am yeah yeah can you talk a little bit
about that pivot
yeah sure absolutely um i
i bought the dream richard i
i was told that if i made decent grades
and i went to play college football
um that i would get a college degree and
i grew up in a pretty poor family so
that i quit playing baseball and
basketball and i went and played college
football
and so i chose construction management i
was told it was 100 job placement
and that i would be sitting in dallas
with a truck allowance and an office
making
75 to 100 000 a year you know probably
starting off at like 60 and making my
way to 100 having health care 401k and i
didn't know any better
and um
[Music]
i graduated college in 2009 so that
didn't happen
luckily for me
i read a book called rich dad poor dad i
think i don't think that that's
something super
original but i did read it my junior
year in college and so i kind of had it
in the back of my head and because i was
forced into not really being able to get
that job
which i'm actually really grateful for
because i think that would have been a
scary thing to fall into
i went and i dug ditches for a company
called austin bridge and road
in a small small town in north louisiana
that job ended i came home
i um i waited tables at uh character
area called texas brazil in baton rouge
and it was really honestly probably the
shittiest time of my life i was really
struggling with uh
missing my my college girlfriend i broke
up with
miss louisiana
at the time
because i had monogamy issues and i
didn't want to lie about it or i didn't
know how to confront it i didn't know
how to be the person i am today so i i
had that going on i missed the girl i
had a [ __ ] job like the whole thing the
whole thing was completely [ __ ] it was
probably the hardest time in my life
and so i'll read at that point was that
still around 25 was that a little bit
older yeah yeah it was right there at
that point okay i i'd left the girl
because my head was spinning and i
wanted to
explore my options but i i didn't know
how to express that to her in a way that
would
um
keep the frame if that makes sense i
just didn't know what i didn't know
and i broke up with her couldn't recover
she actually uh met a brazilian six foot
four brazilian guy
i will say that she did come back years
later
and she kind of lied to me about things
that were going on there but uh i'll
digress but
um
so i ended up getting the upper hand in
the end but i was kind of already this
guy when that happened if that makes
sense you know how they are
and so
they always come back in the end
yeah yeah yeah so
it was it was one of those situations
where
my fitness wasn't there my money wasn't
there i didn't know what to do
everything i've been told about what i
should do was absolutely [ __ ] wrong
you know i say all the time that college
in my opinion and
what were the biggest lies that you had
to unplug from that were wrong you know
because there's a lot of stuff that we
use guys are
fed like a lot of beliefs that kind of
plug you into the matrix um you know
that don't really serve you so what were
the biggest slides that you know that
you had to unplug from
man
that you could live in a neighborhood
the size of your boss's neighborhood by
working for his company you know
um
female nature
how love works what love is
how women work
that that's probably one of the biggest
unplugs
that i had to go through in my adult
life and that didn't happen until i was
into my 30s
i want to get to the women in a bit
later but i want to kind of talk more
about money and business right now so
yeah
yeah it's a little bit more about like
the unplugging when it came to money and
wealth creation and you know setting
your life up
absolutely um
i had a lot of advice when i first
started my metal building company to
stay small
what do you mean by metal building is
that those like um
like the frameless
like like the big aluminum buildings
where you can drive trucks through or
boats yeah
um yeah i think costco yeah we do a lot
of costco's airplane hangar so when
you're sitting on the tarmac okay you
look out and you see the airplanes
flying uh kind of kind of going into the
big buildings and storage buildings
we build those uh walmarts um big rooms
to go big steel structures okay um
b i was i was told
to you know
grow slow stay small
don't let it get too big you go out of
business but i actually found that in
the end it's like if i wasn't constantly
growing i was dying
you know so i really had to be in a
position where i would grow revenue
because what would happen
is i would be scared that we couldn't do
the work that i won
but if there was no work because it
would rain or jobs would get delayed or
whatever i didn't lose my men or worse i
would pay my men to stay to sit at home
waiting on a job
and so one of the things that really
um
helped me was getting over worrying
about growing too big
and really kind of going after it and
really creating business systems i did
um i did a lot of coaching with e-myth
that robert e gerber
smith i did a year and a half coaching
with them at about 27 when we started to
get to about around 2 million in revenue
and it really helped me out i built a
lot of systems put a lot of things in
place and
and really kind of went against
everything that people were telling me
and my dad actually not that he was a
business person but he would constantly
be telling me you know son aren't you
worried about growing company too big
don't shouldn't you shouldn't you be
worried don't you think that that you're
going to grow too big when is enough
enough enough and that was probably
somewhere around a million a million too
and
and the problem with that was was always
was always simply like
yeah but if i it if i think i have this
job and it gets pushed back three months
well i have to pay payroll to those guys
so all the profit i would have made on
that job i'll lose
i constantly be creating ways for
revenue and just adding men adding and
adding men so i'd have this core
capacity of men
and i would have to find ways around it
like subcontract jobs out so which led
me to have to create kind of scripts for
negotiating and sales and and finding
new manpower new systems to find more
guys we we constantly are bidding jobs
but we're constantly recruiting
every day because i always tell my
people it's kind of like if sailor on
this side find a manpower on this side
that project meets in the middle
and
and if i don't if if i let either one of
those legs get bigger than the other
then then i will find myself in trouble
do you have any issues right now um
like you still run the business the
metal building business yes yeah do you
have any problems right now with
staffing issues because one of the
things that i've seen here i've got a
few friends uh that run some businesses
in construction and uh they have a real
hard time
attracting and retaining competent
workers
you know workers are either not
interested or they're lazy or they call
in sick or they got like issues they got
addictive personalities and they're
addicted to drugs or stuff like that do
you have any issues with your businesses
and if you do like how do you solve
those
yeah so
it's the biggest problem that all of us
have i think a lot of our success
uh comes from our ability to navigate
through it
i have i have scripts
for everybody that calls in i have a
very specific way
that i i'll probably never say out loud
that we find these men
and talk to these men
and
and kind of caress a relationship
between us and those men
during the pre-interview process
interview process and even when they're
actually on working for us
it's one of we treat our guys and i
believe this if a guy is working for me
he's buying me
so what do you mean by that
well so for example like you know a lot
of times in construction you'll go to a
client and you'll tell them all the
reasons why we'll treat them well and
you'll do all these certain things it's
not so much that we baby or pamper the
men but we kind of understand
their position and we
try to do things to keep them buying
into the company
and coming back uh simple things you
know birthday parties maybe and and even
there's times where you know i'll turn
up and start putting money in their
pocket because what they do is very
dangerous
i'll take them to get beer i'll you know
i treat them
you know a certain way and i've got guys
that
would absolutely kill for me and then i
have guys that are kind of distant maybe
mercenaries in a way but that that that
problem right there is is the number one
problem in construction and it's not
just
it's not just in my trade it's in every
trade and it's nationally it's it's
something that when i go to my board
meetings for the metal building
contracts and directions association it
is the number one thing
that is brought up
because when you look at it
the american kid doesn't want to do it
i feel like because of social media if
if a guy says he's working with his
hands
it's not appealing to women the
internet's basically told him he failed
because he's not drop shipping from
beach selling amazon it's true
absolutely true
i'm agreeing with you my man
it's it's not a very sexy thing to do
like it's a hard pitch it's a hard hard
pitch yeah i've said it before man like
if you've got a woman that's looking at
a guy that's a junior lawyer you know
the law firm making 60 70 grand a year
versus a guy that might be like running
a plumbing company you know he's got
plumbers that work for him and he's
making quarter million like he's paying
himself well
she's probably going to pick the lawyer
just because he looks like better arm
candy right
yeah it's true look i
when i when i first got started i've
never i've never really had issues
with women like in a major way i
especially when i was kind of already
started the company i was on my way up i
had lots of weight i looked like the
prospect
um
but i'll say there's nothing sexy about
saying i'm a steel erector or i hang
steel and just like you're saying with
the plumber there's nothing there's
nothing really sexy about it
and it's about the way we make our money
too you know you're working with your
hands you have calluses you're on job
site you're wearing boots um i would
constantly have a set of boots
to to go on job sites and a hard hat and
then close and close to go to the bank
to beg for money so i can cover my
payrolls
but it's not the most sexy thing in the
world but if you get it right you can
make you can make
really good money really good so
i always say
that construction
was the only way that we knew how to
make doctor money in boots
that you know and that's that's
literally true i uh i was
literally a redheaded stepchild to a guy
that did metal buildings he would do 35
40s and backyards and that's how i was
kind of conscious of the situation
you